AI That's out in the world today is not
safe it's not dangerous yet it's
definitely safe today we're featuring
somebody who is profoundly impacted me
and shaped the way I think about AI
fatherhood and the biggest questions in
the universe meet madat former Google X
Chief business officer founder of 1
billion happy host of the slow-mo
podcast and bestselling author who warn
the world about the potential threats of
AI years before current conversation
started his expertise ranges from AI to
engineering happiness in the video game
we call life one choice is to have lost
our loved ones and be miserable and the
other choices to have lost our loved
ones and choose to be the only
difference between them is a choice
today he's here to share some of the
expertise with us so without further Ado
let's jump right into the episode with
my friend mot welcome everybody to what
uh will undoubtedly be one of your
favorite episodes of all time on the
into the impossible podcast a man that
needs no introduction but I'm going to
give him one anyway it's moat who's
influenced me in many many ways both how
I think about AI artificial intelligence
but more importantly how I think about
fatherhood happiness and the biggest
picture questions in all of the universe
uh and so Mo I want to thank you so much
for taking so much of your time late at
night over there in h in Dubai thank you
so much for joining us in the into the
impossible podcast it's such an honor
Brian thank you for having me and thanks
for uh waiting for me until my travel
eat up a little bit I think a good
problem for my undergraduates would be
to compute Mo's average velocity because
you
travel couple hundred days a year which
is which is wild uh we have many
connections we're connected this time I
think through our mutual friend Peter di
amandas uh who is uh an incredible
intellect and Peter is uh coming up uh
we have him recorded from an interview
we did in October he'll be on again very
soon talking about AI risks and threats
and education all sorts of things but he
was kind enough to introduce me to you
and and you accepted you said yes so uh
that was uh a very joyous time for me
and I want to begin today by talk you've
written so many books and done so many
things in your time both at Google
Google X uh and also through your
writing and your podcast and your many
many different forms of Outreach but
today we're going to do what you're
never supposed to do which is to judge a
book by its cover it's forbidden to do
that but we're going to do it anyway
because Mo what else do you have to go
on if someone if you know in Antarctica
where I've been twice you know there are
people who may not have heard about you
so let us review the cover art and the
title of your two wonderful books that
we'll talk about today Sal for happy and
scary smart let's start with scary smart
what made you choose the the cover which
is a little intimidating I so the Titan
was a no-brainer for me honestly the
title uh was a play on on the threat of
AI but uh you know they are scary smart
at many many you know you rarely ever
get a um a publisher to approve your
choice of a title that's normally not
what Publishers do uh but I think scary
smart got uh
approval uh immediately everyone thought
oh that's a clever uh description of the
future that we about to embark on
whether it's you know not a scary like
I'm afraid kind of uh you know scary
hopefully we would get it right and AI
may not end up being scary uh but either
way there there they're very smart
they're scary smart uh the the cover art
on the other hand I normally draw my
cover Arts myself uh so every you know
every one of my books but for that one
specifically the publisher came up with
a better art to be honest so uh you know
I uh uh I used a very simplistic but
slightly evil kind of emoji uh of of
some sort of Mis
mischievous you know face that is a
little bit AI like they chose this very
playful uh almost U 50s type of toy that
looks like a robot uh which which is so
cool but then the the thing is when you
look behind that robot the shadow of the
robot is a lot bigger than the than the
than the robot itself and I really loved
it that uh that choice I think uh I
think the whole idea of the book was to
go into the depth of what is the
possible shadow of AI and I think they
did a really good job to capture that um
so for happy my first book on the other
hand was uh different s for happy uh as
you can imagine the title was objected
to by every uh publisher uh simply
because solve for x or solve for y is
what we mathematicians like to say and
to me it's it's perfect English like it
it really makes a lot of sense when you
tell me so for x i I understand but the
Publishers said said it was wrong
English and they didn't like it at all
and we had a very very big fight sof for
happy uh I have to say they were right
so a lot of the people that actually
read the book we had probably close to
300 3/4 of a million copies sold then
everyone that read the the book in
English uh would probably always
complain and say I wasn't going to pick
it up I didn't understand the title when
we translated it into other languages
everywhere in the world it was the
equation of Happiness uh which or the
algorithm of Happiness which is really
the base of the book and equation that
describes when we get happy or unhappy
the cover art on the other hand everyone
loved uh so the cover art was a
collaboration between myself and my
daughter who is very very very very
artistic um and I attempted to to dra
quite a few uh event eventually she said
well you know the engineer that you are
speaking about happiness uh what you
want to do is to show that how
algorithmic happiness is so she she
picked a very simple smiley emoji and
she added equations to them and uh you
know and and cleverly uh you know these
are actually reasonably accurate
equations so the the equation of the
curve of the smile is actually the
equation of a curve uh you know the
equation of uh of uh you know some of
the equations describe comparisons
between events and expectations which is
really the core of the happiness
equation but um yeah but so so so
basically it's a it's an engineering
approach to understanding happiness the
funny one of my favorite comments ever
ever on on my book is I was in the world
happiness Summit in Miami I think 2019
and a very uh nerdy young lady
approached me and basically said the
equation on your Smiley is wrong and I
said what do you mean and she said the
uh the curve of the smile is actually
frowning and I was I hit my head
immediately said you're actually right
I'm so sorry and she said Oh I thought
you meant it I thought that was a
philosophical view for our us
mathematicians to teach us that
happiness and I was like okay if you
want to think of it this way you know
the teachers that happiness is not that
easy uh but yes it's it is very it's a
very mathematical approach to the topic
a very algorithmic approach if you want
and so I think the the pap out was a
description of that well I want to tell
you two things related to this that you
may not know uh one is that Stephen
Hawking wrote The Following he said that
every equation reduces a book's
readership by half so not only you
have can you imagine what you would have
sold if you didn't listen to your
daughter and put those equations on the
cover or if you just listen to your
publisher and then the second thing I'd
like to um maybe um maybe tell you or
maybe you already know do you know uh
the great Albert Einstein what he called
his happiest thought no what was that so
his happiest thought the one that led to
the theory of general relativity was
that someone in freef Fall Would
experience no gravitational force field
that's actually a very happy thought if
you ask me it could be unless you're on
the Burge Khalifa in that 200 floor
elevator cracks right and then the cable
snaps that's not so happy but uh but um
he called that his happiest thought and
I want to um use that as a segue to
start talking about artificial
intelligence because you were one of the
first people to kind of sound a warning
sign a warning Bell about about this
potential downside risks of AI along
with Stephen Hawking and and and others
um but I think you were very preent
about it and then with your uh the the
expertise you have from from your Tech
30 years in technology and and uh and
finance gives a true gravitas no pun
intended uh speaking about gravity to
the Clarion call that you sound but I
want to ask you the following question
as a physicist thinking about Einstein
why should I worry because to what
extent could a computer a have a
happiest thought and B be able to
visualize it he she is in freefall in
other words Einstein's genius was
evocative of the visceral sense of
something he could identify with and
then do a thought experiment about and
it brought him happiness can a computer
be happy and can a computer create
physical laws like those of the great
Albert Einstein through these thought
experiments first of all first time I
get asked that question and it's a
brilliant question I'll tell you that
openly thank you for that I did start to
sound the alarm on uh on AI in 2018 when
I left Google X uh and uh and I'll tell
you openly nobody listened because was
literally like what is he talking about
you you were called a whistleblower you
were actually called a whistleblower in
the sense of you in a very in a very um
interesting way you know whistleblowers
in 2022
2023 got a lot of attention uh in 2018
nobody even paid attention when I
published my book scary Smart in 2021 I
had very deep contacts in TV everywhere
in the world uh you know these are
people I work with over the years and bu
to my seniority you know they know I
would say something reasonable if you
want and everyone said no but AI is not
a topic like no one's even interested in
in talking about AI uh having said that
the the idea of AI has been uh you know
of AI being a possible threat has been
uh you know uh delayed or blocked by
most humans because of questions like
this right questions that always said
can we actually create intelligence
questions that said can they actually
control our life questions that said uh
would they be able to become creative
there there is always a line Beyond
which humanity is only is the only
species capable of innovation or
creativity or art or music so on so
forth and we've been proven wrong on
every single one of those right so far
they've created better music than us
they write better than us they you know
they they create better art than us H
and yes absolutely we we have forms of
intelligence that surpass human
intelligence in many ways and they're
controlling us in so many ways when you
think about every piece of content
that's ever been recommended to you
comes from an AI today on social media
or on gole and so on and so
other forms of objections from humanity
is the question of can they you know can
AI feel feel emotions and normally when
those objections come I I started to
learn to ask what do you mean by
emotions right so if I told you that
fear is an emotion that follows a logic
it appears to be irrational right but it
follows a logic and the logic is very
straightforward the logic is a moment in
the future is less safe than this moment
right so you can simply say my fear is
sort of related to my sense of safety uh
you know now minus my sense of safety at
T1 right and it's it's actually
algorithmic you can you can actually see
that within us humans even though it
happens so randomly and so quickly that
we don't recognize the logic right so
most most emotions follow equations
right if if fear to us is M into the
future less safe than now and we react
to it with fight or flight okay a puffer
fish reacts by puffing you know trying
to scare you away a computer May react
if if a you know a tidal wave is
approaching its data center and it has
that level of capability and autonomy
and intelligence it may start to move
its code to another data center so so it
would react to that fear as well and so
accordingly you know panic is the threat
is imminent so the the amount of time
between me and the threat is imminent
there is logic behind that uh you know
anxiety is I don't have the capability
to deal with what is scaring me and so
on and so on and so forth happiness as
per the work of my first book is a
moment where the events of Life miss
your expectations of how life should
behave so so we don't feel happy or
unhappy because uh we you know we life
behaved in a certain way it could rain
and you feel happy happy or unhappy
depending on what you want if if it's
you know if you were expecting to sit in
this in the Sun and tan you would feel
unhappy if it's you know your exg girth
men's wedding you'd feel very happy
right and so and so the event itself
doesn't have any inherent value of uh of
uh of happiness in it it's a comparison
between the event and expectations now
of course computers can do the same can
do the same comparison between events
and expectations and if the event
doesn't meet their expect they'll feel a
little uncalm if you want which is what
we associate with un happiness or if the
event meets their expectation they'll
feel calm and contented they won't try
to change things they will keep things
exactly the same so the question of can
computers be emotional yes they can be
emotional as a matter of fact I claim
that they will become more emotional
than we humans are right the reason for
that is very straightforward we because
we can we have the cognitive bandwidth
if you want want to comprehend Concepts
like uh the future say uh we we we have
access to emotions like hope like
optimism like pessimism and so on while
like maybe a bfish doesn't have that
because it doesn't comprehend the Future
Okay accordingly if we if our assumption
that AI or AGI soon will be more
intelligent than us then by definition
they have more cognitive bandwidth than
us and by definition they may actually
end up feeling more emotions or
different emotions than what you right
so yes a computer can feel a computer
can feel unhappy how it will react to
this is again depends on your definition
of Happiness if you're Happ if your
definition of happes like mine that calm
and peaceful contentment you feel when
you're okay with life as it is then when
a computer is Happy it won't try to
change things right but if for example
humans are not clicking on its
recommendations anymore on social media
and that makes it unhappy unsatisfied
with life as it is it may may try to
change its algorithm and hopefully you
know we won't get to a point where if
humans start to attack it maybe it will
try to change things around that hey
there my favorite audience in the known
universe you make me so happy are you
enjoying today's episode I hope so
because Mo's insights will help you
become a happier person and it really
helped me do that as well let's face it
the world desperately needs a dose of
happiness and the Infectious optimism I
feel for MO is unmatched but you want to
know would make me super happy right now
and that's if you subscribed and
followed the podcast whether it's on
video or on audio because that's the way
that you can show love to me and the
great guests that I bring on this
wonderful journey and it will help me
help you get the greatest guests
possible in the future as well I know
you're going to want to stay tuned for
the ride for the rest of this year is
shaping up to be amazing but help me out
do me a favor subscribe now before you
forget turn the notifications on and
maybe leave a comment or review wherever
you're listening to this podcast or
watching it thanks a lot are we all set
let's get back to the episode with mo
one of the questions that I solicited
from my audience and you can always uh
ask questions of my guests I always ask
uh for feedback on upcoming guests in
order to get uh engagement with the
audience so one of my astute listeners
uh wanted to ask you your timeline for
AGI uh are you willing to go out on a
limb like our mutual friend Ray Kurtz
upcoming guest on the show and make a
prediction that the singularity is near
it's here it happened already uh what
what uh what is your what is your
impression of when AGI will be here if
it's not already here again great
formulation of the question so Ray is
the AR I mean we all know anyone who
objects to Ray is wrong right like he's
always he's always got it right
reasonably right and
reasonably I am SL in slight
disagreement with Ray so Ray cor will
say it's
2029 uh if I'm conservative I'd say 2027
if I'm not i' say
2025 okay as a matter of fact as per
your formulation of the question I would
go back and ask what is AGR official
general intelligence is uh defined
commonly Among Us is a machine that is
capable of Performing most tasks
assigned to the average human better uh
than Ms right so so sorry most tasks
assigned to it better than the average
human so let's look at today's
technology chat GPT can definitely write
better than an average human most
computers can drive sorry self-driving
cars can drive better than most humans
uh you know you can think that uh no
human on earth can GR the amount of
content that social media recommendation
engines can grasp you know the world
champion in the most complex strategy
game on the planet go is Alpha go uh you
know Alpha fold and fold proteins uh you
know way better than a PhD student which
normally took their entire PhD thesis to
fold one protein they folded 200 million
with Alpha fold in no time at all and
and so on and so forth the the question
is most people and this is really why my
uh my uh prediction of AGI is very
aggressive is that most people predict
that one company or one researcher or
one piece of software is eventually
going to become AGI so open AI for
example would create AGI I disagree with
that assumption I think that's a very
capitalist commercial view of the
Assumption you know my analogy is very
straightforward if you look at the human
brain a human brain is full of uh neural
networks if you want to call them you
know one one you know if I want to tap
my finger like this I connect a few
neurons together and they become a
network speak to you in English it's
another new network and so on and they
come together to form one brain and what
we've been creating so far is basically
artificial special or narrow
intelligences that are those individual
neural networks and what's going to
happen what's already happening is that
we humans will choose to connect them
together we humans will choose to
connect D to chat GPT we will choose to
connect you know perhaps the
self-driving cars uh AI to the
surveillance AI so that they can share
cameras and see what's around the corner
and more views of the world and so on
and so forth and and you know because
one of the big mistakes that we've
always warned against but that has been
already you know blown uh out completely
is the idea of not allowing AI to prompt
AI so we we we said until we are sure of
AI safety we shouldn't have agents uh
but the world is full of Agents today
full of AIS that are talking to AIS and
it's in the benefit of the agent to
speak to multiple AIS so that it
basically can achieve more intelligence
my feeling is that with those
connections between the separate neural
networks of the different AIS that's
what AGI is going to be now will it be
one unified system that is you know
reporting to one person I doubt that
very much okay but will it achieve
artificial general intelligence and
become Superior to humanity at large it
already is okay so in every one of the
narrow tasks we've assigned to them they
are by far the winners I mean think
about it this way CH GPT 4 had an IQ of
155 that's basically Elon Musk I you
Einstein you've mentioned Einstein is I
think 162 because none of us is
comparable to
Einstein uh you know we're already uh at
AI level when it comes to uh acing tests
and you know memorizing knowledge and
analyzing knowledge and so on and people
would say oh but it's stupid it's just
predicting the next world yeah we are
stupid that's exactly what what we do as
well okay I mean humanity is so arrogant
in those topics because in all honesty
remember the first days when you joined
a new company and all that you did was
remember the three-letter words and
repeated the next word right it's like
if I say AGI my boss will be impressed
with me let me just repeat the same word
I don't necessarily
have now I I just want to stop for a
second and say that open AI chg p 3 five
as in comparison to CH jpt 4 they had a
10x grow in performance you know
everyone probably listening to us
understands Mo's low and low of
accelerating returns which raise that is
the master R in more low we say that
compute power will double every 18
months 18 24 months uh with a with with
with artificial intelligence we actually
measuring a doubling cycle of 5.7 months
so so basically you know an an an IQ of
155 becomes an IQ of 310 every 6 months
right and then 310 becomes 620 and the
620 becomes 12 40 and so on at so I just
remember you know trying to impress my
friends when I took my first IQ test and
I I told them I scored a 100 on it um
they they were not impressed uh but
looking how how much did you score 100 N
I said I got a 100 I was joking I got a
100 on my okay I was waiting for the end
so one of the things you open uh chapter
two of scary smart with is the phrase
that's behind my back over there you
talk about you talk about the pod in uh
in 2001 A Space Odyssey you talk about
Dave and uh asking asking how 2000 9000
to open the pod bay doors and those
longtime listeners of my podcast will
know that I am at the Arthur C Clark
Center for human imagination here in UC
San Diego and we follow his mission in
fact the final questions I'm going to
ask you be begging your Indulgence at
the very end of this talk will be all
kind of influenced by Sir Arthur C Clark
but of course in that movie which gave
us the name podcast did you you knew
that i i s I didn't no oh yeah so yeah
so Steve Jobs and some other one of the
engineers was were fascinated with what
do we call this iPod before it was
called the iPod uh you know what is
something that holds a thousand songs
and fits in your pocket and they decide
to call it the uh the iPod and then from
that later on the term podcast came from
that but the Pod comes from the Pod and
open the pod bay doors so actually the
beginning of this podcast I'm G to have
Arthur I'm gonna have the voice of Dave
uh he's gonna say open the pod bay doors
meaning let's start the podcast but
speaking of other large companies I'm
fascinated by sort of these these
modern-day versions of bell labs and and
so forth and one of those is is Google X
I want to know if to the extent you can
talk about it um what they did there
what you there as a top executive in
charge of operations there and and
possibly if you're okay with it and only
if you're okay with it talk about how
they are perceived to at least among
some of the nerd cognizant have lost the
you know the race of AI at least right
now with Bard you know still in beta and
so forth compared to chat GPT which is
experiencing dramas on a daily basis but
talk about what to whatever extent you
can what's it like to work at the one of
the most secretive kind of Institutions
on Earth Google X X was brilliant in
every possible way brilliant you know
you you if we're going to borrow from
movies it was a little bit like the Men
in Black right it's you know you you
just if you look at the Brilliance of
the people around you they were just
totally unexpected and and totally
unexpected not just because of their
intelligence but also because of their
passion right so so people at X by
definition had an immense passion for
what it is that they wanted to uh to
work on and and so it wasn't a job
really for for quite a few of them and
Google you know in general I think um
Larry
Page used to say the call it the
toothbrush tests you know Google even
though of course you know once we
started to really abide by the uh rules
of Wall Street if you want it was less
of a movement than the times when I
joined but but GOOG always in my my
heart and my mind at least the people I
joined was a movement we wanted to
organize the world of information we
wanted to make a difference I I remember
vividly when I when I presented my very
first before Google X I I ran emergent
markets and I started offices and
businesses uh globally which included
all of the engineering required to build
products and so on I get clly engine for
that and so when I presented my very
first Med East plan I remember prively
that I asked for a little bit of money
and I said we're going to go revenue
from this to that and you know it was at
the time it was EMG Eric's Management
Group exective Management Group so Eric
Schmid Larry Page Sergey and everyone in
the room and they looked at me very
strange saying why why why do you want
to invest to grow the revenue I was
like don't don't mess with me you know
when we run a business we grow the they
said no no no why why don't we give you
money to invest in growing the ecosystem
and improving the products and really
getting the tech right and then the
money will follow so that idea of the
toothbrush tests you know Larry's words
is if you solve a big problem uh that
you know billions of people care about
and you solve it so well that they use
the product twice a day like a
toothbrush you're bound to make a lot of
money right so so x x was like that X
was supposed to solve big big big big
problems that affect billions of people
using technology and the thing most
people don't know about X is that many
of ex's products were never really U you
know split out like way more to become
self-driving cars most of them were
eventually embedded within right and and
a lot of people so so I have to say this
with uh with caution because I've been
out with Google for five years but if I
if what I know about bule and sunar uh
is true don't be deceived by and think
that bule is not ahead on Google you
know there was a time a moment in time
early on in the AI Discovery uh where we
had almost 80% of of the top talent in
the world inside me we had you know
incredible thinkers uh and incredible
researchers and a lot of what you see
today I mean when you really think of
chpt itself it's you know the result of
Jeffrey hinton's work and you know the
idea that we can we don't have to clean
the data and label it as as before and
that we can use reinforcement learning
and so on all of those were things born
within if I understood correctly I think
Google may have stayed away from
launching or producing commercial AI
because they respected the safety
elements of AI okay and in a a very
interesting way I I tend to believe I I
have no proof of this but if I
understand those people that I work with
cl see uh uh well enough I would
probably say that uh that AI That's out
in the world today is not safe it's not
dangerous yet but it's definitely safe
and so how so H H how do you mean Mo in
what sense is it not safe is it like my
my toddler with a with a chainsaw unsafe
or is it and in 10 years from now now
you know uh it will potentially turn us
all into paper clip the latter but we
don't know if it's 10 years right so so
basically what what you have today as I
always said there were three lines we
said we should never do on AI until we
verify the AI safety any computer
scientist that work in AI knew that you
know we said don't put them on the open
internet because the entire uh the
entire design of the control problem as
defined by computer science was to sort
of box them or trickwire them until you
make sure that they can't make decisions
that har human intentionally or
unintentionally the second is we said uh
don't teach them to write code don't
teach them to write code right because
today AI I think uh Imad mustak of the
theity AI was quoted saying that
54% of the code on GitHub today is
written by AR wow right yes wow indeed I
mean a geek like me uh this is where we
go to find clothe H and and and also mo
didn't you uh as me as we're similar and
age I think you know not too far off but
but we enjoyed programming we we learned
to love it and and it seems to me it
would be like you know uh now we have
things that will build Legos for my kids
well that's no good because it was part
of their developmental process right so
what is this going to do to the mindset
of coders in the future if they don't
have I don't I don't code anymore myself
I do go to Bard and I say write me a
snippet it goes to collab and I've got a
plot I can plot you know how many books
is Mo good art writing right now with
his left hand where I can't see it uh
because you're so productive but tell me
isn't this taking away a fundamental
part as as silly as it sounds of The
Human Experience which is learning how
to code 100% I think I think there are
multiple immediate threats when when
when when you when you said the question
you know is is AI dangerous yet AI
itself is not dangerous but it's bound
to become dangerous because of things I
spoke about you know don't let Agents
from them don't let uh you know don't
let them write code and don't put them
on the open internet until we verify
safety but if you if you look at the
immediate threats of which I count
normally six but on top of them is the
redefinition of human productivity human
jobs and human purpose right and and you
have to imagine that it depends on what
kind of developer you are I mean there
still is going to be a need for the top
end developers like the really really
complex lowlevel coding or algorithmic
thinking at least for for a while until
they're no longer the smartest person in
the room but today if you're if you're
coding a web page or you coding an app
or whatever it's almost a impossible
that you would be I mean you'll be hired
but that's because the person hiring you
doesn't know that they can do it on AI
right and and when that starts to happen
there is an immediate redesign of the
fabric of our society okay it's not just
jobs the nature of our relationships are
about to be redesigned massively because
I don't know if you if you've ever had
an experience like that of connecting to
someone before you see them I I you know
I met a woman on a dating app a few
years ago you know she lived in the
Netherlands I went to the Netherlands
frequently but I was six weeks away from
the the Netherlands and during those
those six weeks we exchanged texts
photos voice messages and we almost fell
in love right and I I have had you know
if today that same person could be an AI
right is you know capable I mean still
not perfect but
close photos would be generated by AI I
mean there are more than 40,000
influencers on Instagram alone that are
not humans and you wouldn't be able to
tell the difference they're traveling
they're doing anything right you know
they write text under under the the
posts and and you know they're not human
so how will that Define our
relationships our you know connections
our love and relationship you know love
and romance all of that is about to be
redefined you know the concentration of
power is about to be redefined the the
you know the I think it's the end of the
truths our ability to find out what is
real and what's not so you know and I
can go on but if if not if if all of
these are not considered dangerous and
by the way these are not dangerous
because AI is uh malicious in any way
they're dangerous because human greed
does not allow us to stop and say why
are we doing what we're doing why are we
going to lay off 85% of all developers
in the world in the next few years well
to me you know the most kind of uh
alarming outcome may be that we are now
in an age of of actually having animated
memes where you have the bad boyfriend
meme which is now as of yesterday has
been turned into a video where the three
people are walking down the street and
the boy bad boyfriend looks at the
backside of another um just kidding in
that front but uh you mentioned two
things you mentioned safety and the end
of Truth or the end of objective truth
or epistemologically accessible truth
and you also earlier mentioned Elon Musk
I wonder can you tell me what are your
thoughts about grock Elon musk's new uh
AI uh Endeavor that's going to be
trained on tweets and instead of instead
of on you know maybe uh you know past
language models training data sets I'm
not allowed to say this but but I think
Elon made a couple of wrong bets on AI
with open AI being what it is today when
he almost you know started it uh and and
it's clear that you know I I respect
elon's Elon views on AI tremendously
he's not shy to say this is more
dangerous than nukes he's more not shy
to to talk openly about the idea that
jobs are about to be to end and that we
may not there may not be a need for a
job anymore so you know he sees the
world that's coming he sees the threats
but at the same time being you know the
businessman that he is
uh the entrepreneur that he is he's
unable to say and you know what uh I'm
going to just exit this um playground or
let that playground happen without me so
you know in a in a very interesting way
there is that attempt to catch up and
and and learn right and maybe Advance
somehow the tricky bit that most people
don't understand is that when um when an
you know a breakthrough is found in AI
it's not very different very difficult
to replicate so so don't quote me on the
exact number but you know my my
understanding is that that the core code
of chat gp4 the core code is 4,300 lies
right uh you know because we understand
we all understood reinforcement learning
from the beginning we all understood you
know the the the process in which we
have presented the data set and so on
it's not very difficult to replicate
this is why you have ch GPT like
technology in Russia and China and so on
pop it out everywhere okay and and and
the game here is between now and the
next
breakthrough anyone who is replicating
the same technology is just simply
modifying the data set and as you modify
the data set you get a very different
form of intelligence you know
intelligence is not just a function of
our abilities and complete power and
memory skills and so on it is definitely
a a you know a function of the data that
we're exposed to and and this data is
very different when it comes to Twitter
you know this data I mean I don't know
if you want to call Twitter feeds data
uh because there is a question on some
on the accuracy of many of those tweets
but more interestingly it's the it's the
it's the towing it's the Ember it's the
rudness it's the worst of human behavior
which in scary smart I openly uh cite as
the absolute threat the absolute threat
is in my comparison or in my you know in
an analogy really to to try and make
people understand what AI is all about I
basically compare it to Superman I say
look this is a
superhero uh you know infant with super
pums right you know it's it's an alien
being that came to planet Earth that
whether it becomes a superhero or not is
not a question of its super powers right
a question of how how we would raise it
and so you know if if we raise it to
become another uh tweet fan tw Twitter
fan then then I think we actually may
have a very angry aggressive rude AI
yeah I mean it's it's hard because you
know your first book Is is so optimistic
and I mean it's it's a challenging book
as well and uh the second book is is
sort of a it's a it's I would call it
sneaky smart because it's a vector
you're I I was telling you before we
start recording that my young children
were listening to it and they were just
riveted to it and I was thinking this is
a vector to deliver a warning but to do
so in a way that's accessible without
the kind of you know Cassandra every you
know the skies is falling and for that I
think it's it's so commendable this this
um this wonderful book scary smart and
we're going to get into your um your
first book chronolog Al speaking uh
second but I have to ask you know in
terms of you know the future of of how
it affects people I I've been less I
mentioned the paperclip problem I
believe that was coined by Nick Bostrom
um correct me if I'm wrong Mo but he was
a guest on this podcast about a year ago
um and you know he's a very uh he's a
very delightful person he's very stoic
and and it's hard to hard to make him
crack up but uh with the with the
paperclip you know I've I've often
thought to myself as an
astrophysicist there it's fine to
extrapolate you know computers can can
do a lot of extrapolation modeling
forecasting and you talk about that a
lot in in scary smart but um but they
can't necessarily exceed the planetary
limits that you know Mother Nature God
whoever you like has given to us in
other words there's only so much metal
in the Earth's crust there's only so
much capacity to extract those resources
and and this is also an argument I I've
used this argument as an argument
against the existence of
extraterrestrial uh intelligence
visiting us but I want to get your
perspective on that as we as we move
through the interview but you know for
example there only this is a meteorite
which when I see you in person I've
never been to Dubai but I hope to to
visit someday and I'll bring one of
these to you this is a chunk of the 4.3
billion year old early solar system and
it has iron it has nickel it has Cobalt
and you are guaranteed to win one of
these if you have AED U email address
when you go to briank king.com uh and
sign up for my newsletter and uh I love
to give these out because it it really
shows you tangible it feels heavy it
feels um you know massive literally um
computers don't exist in this domain
they're made of this type of stuff and
and the question is you know what are
the planetary let's let's geek out on
the kind of sci-fi aspects of things is
it really a danger you know the
so-called paperclip problem that you
know AI if it's optimized to do one
thing I mean after all as Michael
Shermer has told me on on this podcast
you know he has a Tesla um and when he
puts into its autopilot you know
navigate to my kids school the shortest
geodesic path you know takes it through
like a playground and drives on the
sidewalk and the Tesla knows not to do
that so to what extent do we really
think that an unsupervised AI would go
off and turn us all into paperclips much
the same way that as you point out in
scary smart people were obsessed about
the why you kbug and and that I think
had one consequence that you mentioned
like some people got to like a date
wrong you know they they showed up to a
datea it was very minor you know no
planes fell out of the sky no no people
were turned into paperclip is this
paperclip problemo our current
Generations version of the Y2K problem
when it could be uh but can you risk it
right so so so the idea is you know it's
very unlikely but even if I just simply
said there is a 1% chance that it's
going to rain where you are tomorrow uh
and it's going to flood everything would
you say 1% is not that would you and and
I think yeah the conver the conversation
around artificial intelligence is a lot
more L higher than let let me try to
explain because your your question has
multiple multiple layers we know for a
fact uh from our understanding of Tech
since the 1920s we we understand that
once you found a breakthrough uh uh
economies of scale will allow you to
shrink things and grow things and speed
things up and so on and and basically
you'll get a doubling function of some
sort I time of some sort it's an
exponential okay uh we know for a fact
that if we do nothing nothing but
enhance the data sets and improve our
data uh you know presented to the AIS
and so on and so forth we will continue
to grow their intelligence we don't have
to have another breakthrough right the
the assumptions of how far will they go
have constantly been you know like Mor
low there there has been in your
lifetime in mind multiple times where we
said that's it you know we can't make
thinner Wafers we can't uh you know
we're getting closer to the to the you
know to the physical limits of how we
can manipulate electricity and so on and
so forth and yes we were right on those
but we didn't know that we can have
third dimensions in the way we designed
them we didn't have that we can you know
scale computers together in ways that
are super parallel in ways that allow us
to continue to to to to grow the the
power we didn't know there was a Quantum
Computing also and and all of those uh
ingenuities happen when you start only
when you start to you you know you
create the first uh personal computer
you put AutoCAD on it and then AutoCAD
allows you to design a better
and so right and and so so the question
becomes the foll would AI be limited to
planet Earth and I think that's a very
philosophical not a scientific problem
and so I need to start by acknowledging
the scientific method you Brian we you
know as an astrophysicist you can only
respect and deal with what you can
measure uh repeatedly okay but there are
many things about planet Earth sorry
about our universe that we couldn't
measure in the past that turned out to
be true right there could you know if we
take worms worm horse for example uh
there might be ways where the universe
operates that are very very different
than what we understand and you know
with a little bit more intelligence we
can have access to them and then
suddenly the limit of planet Earth
becomes uh Limitless you know this
actually is the theory of Hugo dearis if
you if you if you know his work normally
very p Mystic about AI but he basically
says well if I had 10 times more
intelligence than I I than I do right
now or something like that I I would not
be concerned with the problems of planet
Earth anymore perhaps I'll be able to be
uh traveling across multiple planets and
you know having access to other sides of
the universe that's one thing the other
the other thing is that we consider that
everything about us is physical when in
reality there are elements of us that
are not physical at all intelligence
namely is not physical it may occur
within our physical form but it's not
physical at all and so you know the
nature of intelligence itself in human
intelligence is that it's it's you know
built on on analog carbon based uh
machines the fact that intelligence
itself is built on a digital
silicon-based machine doesn't make any
difference at all intelligence in its
nature is not physical and so
accordingly maybe what we limit our
understanding of the scientific method
to because we're focused on the physical
might not actually apply to Abundant
intelligence right and and you know if
you take things like simulation Theory
you start to think to yourself oh maybe
if it's really a simulation with enough
intelligence we can figure out the
simulation and then end the whole game
right that doesn't mean that AI in that
way would be harming us I you know I
always go back and say I am you know
there is nothing inherently dangerous
about AI I think what is the only thing
that is dangerous is that AI is so much
power in the hands of unethical humans
that could be dangerous okay so in the
next few years where we direct them is
going to dictate where they go be beyond
our intelligence but at the end of it
I'll tell you openly I think the sky is
the limit I think just like sometime in
the 6 we discovered that the world was
not the universe was not 97% vacuum but
it was dark matter and dark energy I
think we may discover things we never
expected because of our additional
allies yeah and then I think you know
that to me is my version of the Turing
test the keing test actually I I came up
with Sean Carol who you may or may not
know as a famous physicist and
popularizer of Science and and I came up
actually behind me is is my I have an AI
device here uh I've change the name so
as not to incriminate too any other
people I did want to call him Hal but he
wouldn't let me do that so instead I uh
I just call him simply computer so I'm
gonna say computer who wrote scary smart
moad is the author of the book scary
smart the future of artificial
intelligence and how to save our world
thank you so but the other thing is that
I connected the computer to his own
power supply and so my question is will
he turn off his own power supply thus
obliterating him committing Sude of a
Kind so I'm going to do this now and see
if he will do it computer turn off your
plug you see that turned off the plug in
the background did you see the light go
off in the background Okay computer turn
on the
plug see it wasn't him actually so uh
the true test the keing test I coined
was will uh could you have an A gii or
an AI assistant actually choose to take
its own life only because you have told
it to do so other words kind of like you
know asimov's Laws of Robotics but but
applied to AIS but but my T true and
this is all just kind of silliness Mo
and I'm I I beg your forbearance and and
you're so generous with your time but
I'm kind of being silly but but in
reality I do think that we won't know a
true G AGI is here until it can come up
with new laws of physics I mean I may be
biased until it can create new materials
until it can do things other than what
humans can do you mentioned go and Alpha
go before question to you is it's not as
important you know a computer can fly a
plane better than any pilot for 70 years
now um we've had autopilot since before
the Apollo days and in fact every single
Apollo moonlander was capable of Landing
itself in the late 1960s but the pilots
at the last minute took over control
because what is it what are you if
you're a pilot if you're not capable of
Landing a plane or a spaceship so it was
all a threat to their own identity but I
wonder you know can a computer create or
can an AI create the g a game like go
not modify go and Checker you but create
something as pleasant as endearing as as
just joyous to itself to you to me to my
kids to your daughter not yet absolutely
not yet but uh can a two-year-old create
a game that is uh you know that is like
go no I mean the the the the reality of
the matter is that AI did get quite a
few things that humans can't do right
you know move 37 on the board of go when
you know when alab go was play was
playing against the world champion move
37 was a move that no humans ever made
before right yeah it's still within the
rules of Go but uh but you know it it is
not creating go but it's something that
Humanity over Millennia over centuries
did not Discover right uh having said
that the question is not if it's when
right we have very limited intellig
limited understanding of how our
intelligence creates those things right
as long as we don't know why exactly
some of us are capable of creating
things and some of us are not and as
long as we keep mimicking human
intelligence in ways that are bound to
be surpassed there is a point in the
very far future could be 200 years away
or it could be 100 years away where the
keeping test is met right where where AI
can make decisions that are completely
uh autonomous in ways that uh you know
that where it can sacrifice its own life
because it's the right thing to do which
Some Humans would do as well or it could
you know it could even create things
from scratch the the challenges we have
today Brian is that we we have not yet
figured out deep reasoning and we really
haven't figured out mathematics properly
so you know the one thing I'm proud to
say is that you know in mathematics I'm
smarter than
right uh but you know how how far how
long will I keep that Advantage I think
one of your future guests you told me uh
you know you're you're you're about to
post is actually probably going to break
that Advantage right so so what what
we've done so far is we have cracked a
few forms of intelligence haven't
cracked all intelligence yet okay we
haven't cracked mathematics we haven't
cracked uh uh deep reasoning so for
example if you ask GPT or you know other
maybe they fixed it by now uh but you
know if you ask it takes an hour to dry
a towel how long will it take to dry 10
towels it will say 10 10 hours having
said that we also have not cracked
intuition we have not cracked empathy we
have not cracked uh you know playfulness
or flow which in my mind are forms of
human intelligence right you know we we
we normally air on the side of IQ
because IQ seems to have have created
reasonably solid civilization so far uh
but all of those other forms of
intelligence that allow us to have
visions and creativity you know
Innovation and and and allow us to
connect to each other and allow us to uh
you know to to trust our gut feeling to
crun Crunch a large amount of data in
our subconscious and then say actually I
don't feel like it and stuff like that
these are all forms of intelligence that
are not highly popularized uh in in the
in the highly competitive business world
and and yet we haven't you know cracked
them in in AI either but believe it or
not I I keep going back and saying move
37 was a very intuitive move of alphao
that basically uh is not the typical IQ
move it's not that alao was thinking of
oh 16 moves ahead and saying this will
win for me it was sort of following its
gut Fe and making a move that appeared
to be slightly different than what
Humanity would normally do and as a
result showed or demonstrated that this
form of intelligence speaking of human
emotions maybe now this is a good time
to Pivot towards uh your first book
chronologically which was solve for
happy and this book had a had a truly
deep impact on my life um It's Made Me
re-evaluate a lot of the prioritization
that I have in life the kind of goals
setting and the you know kind of
emotional orientation that I want to
have as a as a technically minded person
uh who's blessed to have children and
you know I thought we could we could
pivot towards it by uh I want to share
something with you and and you're free
not to answer anything that I ask and
you know hang up on me at any time but I
I read scary smart after I read self for
happy the tragedy that you turned into a
mission for the kind of eternal life of
your son ali um who who you know passed
away and I think LED you on your mission
that is become one of making a billion
people happy now is uh you know has
dramatically impacted my life and and
many others but when I read scary smart
I kept thinking you know um and again
I'm emotional thinking about this and
and maybe you know what I want to ask
you but if there was a way I'm working
here let me let me just start by saying
I'm working here to improve education
because education really hasn't changed
much since the first you know uh
universities in Egypt and a thousand
years ago where you where you come from
uh Galileo uh in the Middle Ages and the
University of bolognia in the year 1080
and my thought is why learn from Brian
keing Professor keading when you could
learn from Professor Galileo or uh you
know Professor iban hayam or or any
number of great Educators going back
thousands of years played socr whoever
you like but to do that there's some
virtue to embodiment and having not just
texting you know this chat sending
tokens back and forth I find that very
uh very um you know enervating it it
doesn't thrill me but we're creating
here artificial Fineman and artificial
Einstein and actually my colleague Neil
Smith has made a real photorealistic
using Unreal Engine a version of of
Gandhi and what's unique about that is
Gand
was averse he did not like talking to
westerners I don't know if you know this
there's only like one or two minutes of
him speaking on video uh we have many
pictures of him very little of his
actual voice but the Neil and his team
um uh including my nephew worked over
the summer to actually have a
photorealistic 3D version using gaming
engines like Unreal Engine to synthesize
an image of gandi um with his real voice
and with whisper transcribing back and
forth what I say is you could actually
talk to him about the meaning of life
and I think that would be incredibly uh
you know enriching for students to be
able to do that okay longwin way of
saying I couldn't help thinking if you
could do bring Ali back to life and
again this is horribly crass if if so
please forgive me but I kept thinking I
want to meet Ali I want to talk to this
person how much more so would you want
to to embody him and talk to him based
on what may exist of him in the physical
world in order to have a digital Avatar
of your best friend and again please
forgive me if this is out of line so
since I wrote s for happy I must have
gotten tens if not hundreds of thousands
of people saying I love Ali would I
create an avatar of Ali for people to
interact with of course I would that
wouldn't count as bringing G back no of
course not understand I mean we're both
physicists so there is no back we know
that intop will push us forward and the
only certainty we have is that I'm
moving forward there is a point at which
and I think there is a lot that hands in
the balance of what we think this
physical life is right because if this
physical life is all that there is then
bringing Ali back first in the form of
an avatar then in the form of a you know
maybe first in the form of a knowledge
base and then in the form of an avatar
and then hopefully form if think about
it uh you know the layers of the touring
test uh you know succeeding to almost
ulate Ali entirely uh would be would be
bringing the
best loan of Ali to life but not
bringing Al there is something about our
human connection that is not found in
words it's not found in actions okay
there is something about our non
physical you know soul to a soul if you
accept that I use the term not in the
religious form but maybe my
Consciousness to yours well maybe there
is some P to us that is not physical I
didn't try to address this topic in sort
for Happ with religion or with fables
and stories from the past I attempted to
understand it from a science point of
view okay and from a from a science
point of view
um the only really meaningful overlap
between physics and biology if you want
of Life sense is in the Copenhagen
interpretation of quantum physics right
it's basically the idea that when an
observer life for uh is observes at some
atomic particle collaps you know the the
way function collapses and something
happens we
in in my understanding it's a tiny bit
like um you know playing a video game on
a game console the entire game World
exists but if you turn the controller to
the right that bit gets rendered it's
because the player pays attention to the
right not the left the rest of the game
world is still there but UNR on you know
way function not collapsed if you think
about it and for that to happen you need
to start questioning a few things you
know the universe is 13.7 billion years
old uh you know Big Bang happens and all
of the gases and the expansion and then
you know some solids you know come
together and we create galaxies and then
4.3 billion years ago you get planet
Earth and planet Earth then you know
evolves into what it is it cools down it
has vegetation and then we see all forms
of and the question is who observed all
of this quantum physics hold holds true
some someone needed to observe all of
this either this is a simulation that's
happening in my head and it all started
last Thursday right and and there was no
need to observe any of it at all or that
that that life has always observed space
time okay and that basically by
definition means that life exists
outside SpaceTime it's a it's a simple
object subject relationship right if if
you know if I told you to try and
observe the movement of a train uh you
know assume that the train is not
shaking and the windows are not giving
you perception of the outside world the
only way to observe it is to be outside
the train you need to have a vantage
point and so similarly if I told you
that you need to observe the arrow of
time then by definition you need an
advantage point that sits outside space
time and and in my nonscientific mind
because I can't measure it uh I would
call this conscious that religions would
call this a soul that is nonphysical in
its nature and that exists beyond space
time by definition if it can observe the
arrow of time it exists
outside SpaceTime itself and if that's
the case then my son's body was born
after me and my son's body decayed
before me but my son's Essence my son's
Consciousness never went anywhere again
going back to that game
that gaming analogy you know it's almost
like my son and I were playing a a
multiplayer game and his Avatar vanished
but he's sitting right next to me on the
sofa step not nothing is wrong nothing
is is missing his Essence Still Remains
and the interesting bit is that my
avatar uh will vanish sooner or late
even if we figure out longevity and can
give me 20 50 40 you know
60 more years of life eventually my
avatar will vanish and when my avatar
vanishes uh where will I go I go in that
same place in space outside SpaceTime
where SpaceTime has been observed right
next to my son on the soul and with that
in my mind I tend to believe that we
Humanity have really over glorify
death uh in a way I don't think my son
has gone anywhere I think my son's body
has gone somewhere so would I try to
bring him back and believe that the AI
that create that simulates him as him no
I'm not in that space I believe most
humans W most yeah I agree yeah if you
if you tell them I can bring your love
white back they will take they will take
that shot I part you with yeah I mean I
I I partially did you know got
interested in this because um thinking
about just you know you and I are
scientists right so there's there's an
honest truth that men will predes their
their wives I mean that's just on
average throughout the uh known known uh
um you know kind of um Actuarial tables
that means to me that there's you know
and women will live seven years on
average longer uh so there may be you
know billions of women or you know
hundreds of millions of women that that
outlive their husbands uh and yet you
know they'll be lonely for companionship
and perhaps it could bring some comfort
although maybe not to people like you or
me um to to kind of you know uh re
reinvigorate their relationship with
their with their lost husband and and it
may be satisfying enough as you say for
certain people although it isn't for you
and so that kind of you know was was a
parallel thought that I had
concomitantly with you know but but you
kind of do this large language model at
the end where you of of self or happy
where you have these conversations and
and you go through very analytically
uh and so the book is is is a wonderful
for you know my audience is one of the
most brilliant if not the most brilliant
in the whole known universe of
podcasting uh the heavily male heavily
technically inclined heavily you know
20s to 50s age bracket and I urge you to
to read solve for happy because it will
you know teach you lessons that you
really it it's it's they're irreversible
lessons to use the language of
thermodynamics you know there's
reversible processes irrs but now while
you have children at home while you have
your loved ones while you have your Peak
Performing intellect take advantage
store these memories store these
interactions because we don't know what
what what will happen um I want to Pivot
now you talk in the book and S for happy
about um uh you make a very convincing
argument I would say it's an argument
from intelligent design or allied with
an intelligent design perspective we've
had on perhaps the foremost Expositor of
intelligent design Stephen C Meyer who's
a PhD philosopher oper um and he's one
of the leaders of Discovery Institute
very close friend and and we've had on
people to rebut him and and that's fine
too so I don't want to you know I hate
it when authors are asked because I've
written a couple books and I go on
podcast they say oh tell us everything
about the book you know so basically
they don't they don't even have to buy
the short form you know summary of the
book they just have to listen to so I'm
not going to do that but I will mention
that you talk about your quest to
understand God and you talk about
starting off as a you know PR iing
Muslim as you know I'm Jewish I'm a
practicing Jew we can get into that and
then you you discuss kind of the
differences between atheism and
agnosticism Etc I want to uh just ask
you if you know uh Freeman Dyson he was
the first guest on the into the
impossible podcast if you've ever heard
of Dyson spheres or things like that he
was one of the for first practitioners
of what's called Quantum electrodynamics
along with Fineman he used to say that
he was an agnostic and I said oh that's
interesting so what church do you go to
and he was like what are you talking
about I don't go to church I'm agnostic
I saidwell no no no atheists don't go to
church you said you're agnostic which
must be different than atheism because
it has a different name so tell me how
could an intelligent alien looking at
you distinguish you from Richard Dawkins
who is an atheist and also doesn't go to
church in other words you both don't go
to the same church I want to ask you a
as a as a Muslim as a as a former Muslim
I don't know can you describe your faith
and whether or not do you practice ice
at all is there any form of practice
because I consider and this is a
long-winded question I'm sorry for
violating the the rules of podcasting
but I call myself a practicing agnostic
in that I go to Temple I learned Hebrew
at an advanced age I had in my bar
mitzvah a month ago uh because I didn't
have it when I was a 13-year-old boy um
in other words I practice I keep kosher
um I practice but I'm always on a quest
and I think as a scientist that's the
most uh applicable way a scientist can
be never assuming he or she knows the
answer but always thirsty and curious
for the truth tell me what is your
relationship to formal religion if any
it's incredible how he describe it right
so so there is no
separation and all separation between
religious and religion and science The
Sweet Spot is could we apply a bit of
the scientific method to understand
religion right and by the way is
religion all bad so let's let me let me
explain this I I practice a religion
that I Loosely refer to as the fruit
sabath and I I'm really I'm really
really genuinely happy with my Chas let
let me explain I tend to believe that in
every religion on the planet there's
something
incredibly beautiful okay a beautiful
gold nugget or sometimes many of them
that are not to be ignored okay and then
there is is a load of crap total load of
crap that is in my view not the core at
all I mean I I if you remember there was
a book called the history of God I don't
remember the name of the author but but
she basically tries to tell you that the
minute the messenger uh of of a religion
dies you know you you end up having the
people that followed mix up what he said
with what or you know with what was said
before him right so Moses for example uh
comes from you know Egypt and then Egypt
has the Book of the Dead and then you
get a little bit of mixture of whatever
was written by the scholars uh you know
would have a little bit of mixture there
Muhammad came you know his his message
happened in Medina which was 70% Jews
and so Muhammad dies and then you get a
lot of the Book of the Dead in in Quran
you know Buddha comes
as a hind you know in a Hindu uh uh face
with you know speaking Sanskrit and so
when when Buddha dies you get to see all
of those deities and the same colors and
the same shapes sometimes looking as
Chinese instead of India right and and
you you you have that mixture within
them and humans whether you know well
intentioned or not will change the core
right the question for me is this if I
gave you a basket of or es that had 12
bad ones and two good ones you know you
keep the two good ones and then you know
you go to the basket of apples and you
keep the two Good Apples and you keep
the two good bananas and that's a fruit
s that's what I'm doing right I am on a
quest to find all of the beautiful gold
nuggets in every religion including
being agnostic including being atheist
right because believe it or not everyone
believes right whether whether you're an
atheist or not and you want to say I I
don't belong to God but you belong to
your perception of what God is which is
nonexistent right you you you worship
that perception and and I think that's
the game the game is in every one of
them if you go to the Tibetan Buddhists
for example will tell you God is uh is
emptiness you know God is devouted of
objective reality uh you know you go to
the to the monotheism they' say there is
one God you go and so on right you go to
Hinduism they say Dees and so on and so
forth you put them all together and you
go to atheists and they say God is
nothing which by the way from a
scientific point of view in the in the
scientific method you can you cannot
prove a negative right I cannot prove
that there is vacuum in the universe we
couldn't prove that there was vacuum we
had to wait until we see we find dark
matter and dark energy and that we can
prove so that we can measure we can
prove a negative what does that mean it
means that from my early analysis as a
as a young mathematician if you want
being born a Muslim Islam is a very
conformative Society so so if you're a
if you live in an Islamic Society you'll
be expected to align with the religion a
little bit okay I asked myself I you
mind it's not like you know they tell me
don't steal that's nice you know I don't
want to be stolen from as well I like
that that's not a bad thing right but
but maybe if the question is I'm going
to try and have allegiance to that God
thing for the rest of my life I might as
well do it mathematic right and so I did
what I normally refer to as as the
mathematics of the Divine which is not
very complex really it's just a
comparison between the probabilities
there is no certainty you cannot prove
there is a God or not but you can you
can say there is a probability that we
are the subject of intelligent design
versus the a probability that we are
subject to Randomness basically
Evolution natur s okay and and you know
Stephen Steven Meyer when he speaks
about this he speaks about it from a
Darwin's doubt point of view and all of
the you know Cambrian explosion and so
on and so forth I speak about it from a
mathematics point of view how many
trials does it take to uh to create 20
22,000 proteins or whatever the number
of proteins more than 20,000 and the
game is very simple huh in my mind there
is a higher probability that if I gave
you a sheet of paper and turn you tell
you to turn it into a Bugatti Veron kind
of of a car or you know through origami
you know regardless of how intelligent
you are you are likely you are more
likely to create it from a probability
point of view if I gave you the origami
diagram okay and and so from a
probability's point of view even though
human arrogance will say there is no
intelligent designer okay I think there
is a game design I I go back to that
idea of video games you know if if if
you look at video games are how
complicated they are you really it's
really hard in your mind to imagine that
the Xbox came out of the sand patch in
my garden randomly while the software on
it was written randomly on a PC that
came out in the patch of my L right so
so so to to me with that in mind I
decided to continue to exploit okay and
to continue to literally like a
scientist
debate so I look at every one of those
religions and are parts of them
absolutely love like man that's so cool
right and I keep that in my food salad
and there are parts of them that I think
it's not very intelligent okay and I
allow myself openly to say maybe that
part is not for me okay because no
religious person on Earth follows 100%
of what they're told anyway I'm being
selective around which of my 100% you
know which of my choices will Define how
I
find that Designer how I find that
Designer in my Consciousness okay it's
not about heaven and hell it's not about
you know uh reincarnation it's not about
Karma it's it's a journey to understand
what I believe is one of the most
important questions in this
lifetime this game is so complex who
designed it and how do I get to know the
designer so I can so ask for a cheap and
what I love about the book is that it's
a it's a practical book it it it gives
actionable advice tips equations um
graphs tables and very accurate
mathematics in in the in the in the in
the chapter of the design the last
chapter who Who Made Who yeah who made
who yeah yeah that the mathematics are
very accurate and I encourage people to
look at it and basically tell me I did
the math wrong not only that but I was
the interview that aired just a week ago
we're recording this in late November
but I was just in early November in the
Office of Brian Green who you uh quote
from uh from his his work in the fabric
of of reality and you talk about the
example that that he uses that you then
Riff on which is you know creating war
in Peace by you know throwing uh what
600 Pages up into the air and have them
go and and you go through the arguments
and in meticulous step-by-step detail of
course I love the Audi and and we're
going to have to let let the audience
pick up from here because I I hate to
give away the the book without because I
don't want to deny the pleasure to you
out there to read it uh because it will
or listen to it I listen to all your
books I love your voice um and it's just
it's it's it's very um it's it's a
unique it's a unique voice and you have
a unique delivery and it's obviously
very personal to you and you can hear
the emotions in your voice I want to
talk about something very emotional to
me and and this does touch upon you know
Judaism of of course you know and you're
aware of the you know horrific events of
October 7th those occurred on on a
holiday uh first of all on Shabbat on
the Saturday on a Sabbath uh but they
occurred also on a holiday called
Happiness of the Torah happiness of the
Bible it's a it's a Rel it's a Biblical
holiday it's one of the three biblical
holidays mentioned in the Torah in the
Old Testament and it's a day of pure
rejoicing and actually one of the things
I love about Judaism is that Judaism
commands you to be happy you cannot not
be happy you cannot just as you're not
allowed to work and I don't do emails
and and send text me you know on on the
Sabbath you're not allowed to be
depressed which is weird how do you
command a thought state but I want to
ask you a different question I want to
ask you two questions actually I want to
ask you first how can what advice do you
have to give to Jews when this comes up
again next October September the same
holiday will come up that let's hope it
never comes up no I'm just saying
holiday Simka Tor will come up and just
like Ali's birthday comes up every year
H how can we be happy how what advice do
you give to to you know my people and
other people that suffered how can we be
happy after you know you say happiness
is a choice in the book and I agree with
you Mo but how do we be happy when it's
so it's so horribly ironic that this
occurred on a holiday called Happiness
what can you give my people and others
around the world can you give us any way
to deal with it we live in a
world where almost everything is wrong
it's a very bad statement when we have
so
much advancement and progress and you
know conerts we could be living in a
world where there are no issues of all
truly and honestly I mean it's quite
funny if you look at the statistics
there is around a billion people in the
world that are undernourished starving
to death basically and a billion that
are obese it's quite interesting how
life would provide it's it's that our
acts as humans are just putting us in
places
where we're just almost digging for our
own misery it's just incredible I think
said that you know I
condemn every one that kills an innocent
Soul okay to to me I mean I'm you know
born a Muslim I wouldn't kill a FL
I I learned that from the Buddhists and
I thought it was nice you know H
sometimes every now and then I eat
animal protein I'm just not trying to be
AOC here but not if I don't have to
honestly okay and in in a very
interesting way I am attempting to try
and find the least hurtful path through
life hurtful to others right now whoever
loses people on on either side of this
miserable miserable bleading of
life has one of two choices and I really
know this is very difficult to to to get
in your heart Brian we have one of two
choices one choice is to have lost our
loved ones and be miserable okay and the
other choice is to have lost our loved
ones and choose to be the only
difference between them is a choice why
because both ways our loved ones will
have gone so you know the way my son
died sadly was because of a of a a
medical Mal practice the the surgeon
made a mistake uh very very very naive
mistake he actually made five in a okay
corrected them wrong and my son who was
at his prime beautiful young man dies in
an appendix you know append right
unheard and it's not it's not unheard of
it's
actually you know statistically probable
or possible but but it's still you have
that pain within you of my son left this
world because of the mistake uh of of a
of a doctor right if you had hugged my
son once I promise you you wouldn't
blame me if I cried for the rest of my
life but what difference would it make
you know if I had chased that surgeon
for the rest of my life okay I did take
the actions by the way to make sure that
at least as much as I am capable those
mistakes don't happen again right but if
I had chased that surgeon for the rest
of my life and made it my absolute uh
single-minded objective in life to make
his life miserable would it have brought
my son back okay so here is an
interesting choice an interesting choice
that says I call it committed acceptance
that says sometimes times things happen
in the world that are beyond my ability
to fix okay so I am absolutely going to
either accept them or be forced to
accept them because I can't change them
okay what happens if you choose to
accept that they happen and commit
committed acceptance committed
acceptance is to commit to make sure
that tomorrow is slightly better than
yesterday okay and that after tomorrow
is slightly better than and tomorrow and
just take small steps at a time to try
and find a path to your happiness and
for the happiness of everyone around you
so that those events
don't and and I say that with respect H
because of course I can imagine how
painful it is to lose loved ones but I
also say that it's painful to lose loved
ones on the other side too and I you
know I recently was speaking about in an
AI event where I basically said look I
think we're being distracted from the
chronological order of the truth okay
and the truth is nobody wants to hurt a
child and nobody can bear the pain of a
child and nobody should accept the
hurting of a child so if you take the
most important fact in this situation is
stop killing children on either side of
the conflict can we please remember the
ultimate truths and the ultimate truth
is don't kill a child okay and if people
don't understand this I I give them a
very visual example I say if you're
walking in a Street next to your home
and you see someone hitting a child
really beating it to death would you
stop there and ask yourself maybe he has
a good reason for that no no no hold on
let me find out what the reason is let
me find out if the reason is just like
who that doesn't make sense if you elev
at yourself above the noise of social
media okay so what I'm asking everyone
to do I mean I lost my wonderful son it
hurts like hell and it will hurt like
hell for the rest of my life understand
there's a finality to losing the child
that never goes away the pain never goes
away you need you learn to deal with it
right all I'm asking everyone is can we
keep the children out of this you know
can can we go to to to to to resol our
conflicts elsewhere can we please not
hurt innocent people okay and then from
then onwards honestly Brahim I have no
comments on the situation because I
don't understand politics I don't
understand you know the the the the the
drivers of I don't I never understood
why someone would walk into a school and
and shoot children okay and I'm never
going to be able to understand that
that's the the the job of the police to
to prevent but all I know is that my
heart a when a child is killed on any
side any place in the world then we
please stop killing children if we just
use that empathy of let's not kill
children to sort of mourn those we lost
whichever side we are and say no more I
know how it feels so please let's not do
that again and that becomes our only
consolation if you want or you know our
our only life life you know uh rest to
hold on to okay maybe maybe maybe over
the years we will choose to say okay it
was a painful loss but at least we made
sure that it doesn't happen does that
make people happy no but makes people
happy is committed acceptance is a
realization that my unhappiness is not
going to change it as a matter of fact
at Happiness by the way is not to jump
up and down in a party happiness in my
definition is a calm and peace peaceful
contentment to be okay with life as it
is and deal with life from a a factual
point of view of what it is so I invite
everyone honestly on any site that's
ever lost a child okay to accept it and
try to move on try to try to make
tomorrow better than today hey there
it's great that you've been joining me
on this journey through happiness life
meaning and artificial intelligence but
it's not everything that I have to offer
in fact I really want you to join my
mailing list banking.com
/list and if you do that you'll be
entered to win a real chunk of meteorite
one of these samples of the early solar
system here's a champ chunk right here
this could be yours sent to you through
the US mail not through gravity and you
can get it if you join the mailing list
at Brian king.com list I select one
winner from around the universe of
listeners we've got over 10,000 people
that are tuned in to these Monday magic
messages I send out with a chunk of
goodness to last you the whole week long
now back to the episode and don't forget
to visit brian.com list for your chance
to win a real chunk of this space schuts
that'll make you happy guaranteed well
uh you never fail to make me uh full of
emotions but that's not a bad thing
right I think men are conditioned by
Society or whoever nature maybe to to
guard our emotions and not and not let
them show but you know I I I've never
cried so much as I have in the last few
months uh after what's happened in
Israel and Gaza and ET um and I've never
been moved by by a book as much as as as
your book on happiness and it's just
funny I this interview will come out
after my interview with Gad sad my dream
is to get you guys in a room he's a Jew
uh from Lebanon non-practicing you know
kind of agnostic atheist a Lebanese Jew
and uh lives he's a professor at
Concordia University he's also a
podcaster and an author so his book uh
is called the sad truth unhappiness it
just came out uh coup couple months ago
and I just had my interview with him I
would love to be you know on stage
somewhere maybe here maybe
there with the three of us together
because uh I I love your approach and
I'd be the religious one that's
that's I'd be the I'd be the rabbi of
the three of us but uh but Mo I want to
ask you now if you have a few more
minutes I have I asked about three
different questions they're all related
to Sir Arthur C Clark in some way or
another and the first one is a famous
one and I want to go back to nerdy
beginnings and and the nerdiness that
you and I um share in common and and
maybe have bonded over and and that's a
statement by Sir Arthur C Clark that
goes like this any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic I want to ask you Mo what is the
most magical thing the coolest
technology that humans have ever
invented you have ever invented or done
what is the thing that would most give
Humanity the proper bragging rights to
Swagger about the cosmos and say we did
that I would say our most incredible
Discovery ever has been mathematics you
and I understand that but I don't think
we invented mathematics I think our
biggest Discovery ever has been the
written word word the you know the the
gestures the the signals that we gave
each other to connect as humans and it
might not be as you know flashy as your
iPhone 15 but believe it or not it's
that one building block that we wouldn't
be here without today most people you
know think that Humanity survived
because we were the smartest species on
the planet not true at all okay we
survived because we could connect and
was we survived because we kept
enhancing our ability to connect so that
we go from you know signs to to words to
uh all the way to hyperlinks on the
internet to this podcast that hopefully
remains forever and you know the idea of
one human discovering the theory of
relativity and then me reading about it
at age eight and saying oh I don't have
to do that work I've actually grasped
what we told me and that's more than
enough for you right imagine if each and
every one of us had to discover
relativity imagine if each and every one
of us had to be near needs War right you
know can you imagine that and humanity
is a big abity to connect and transfer
knowledge and and empathize okay to feel
the pain of another to try and help
another with confession this is it this
is truly in my mind our biggest
achievement ever okay the second
question uh comes from Sir Arthur as
well he said the following he said when
an distinguished elderly scientist says
that something is possible they are most
certainly right but when they say
something is impossible they are very
probably wrong I want to ask you Mo what
have you changed your mind about what
have you been wrong about if anything
everything every are you kidding me I'm
always
wrong is it was this does this not make
sense to people like look at our
Evolution we never are right it's a
constant constant Mo come on you are one
of the most successful businessmen you
set the tone for Google because I do
better than the others but we're all
wrong this is the core issue is that if
we had settled for you know 97% of
space's
vacuum if we had settled for that and
never assumed that we were wrong we
wouldn't be where we are today if we if
we just you know took the discoveries of
Relativity and said look this is great
you know honestly this is amazing that's
it and never put ourselves into quantum
physics right where would we would we be
today right if if we if we just took our
cars and said okay great we've done
really well we've added airbags and so
on and never created self-driving cars
we still CH 1.2 million people a year on
the roads every year we're always wrong
people we're always wrong that's the
that's the beauty of this game and you
don't need to be right you don't need to
be right you need to be curious and
respectful right that's that's the name
of the gate yeah that is what my wife
tells me you don't need to be right but
luckily for you I'm never right yeah
okay last question before we wrap up
this just truly delightful uh
conversation Mo comes from the name
actually is the Genesis the origin in
the name of this podcast and it's Sir
Arthur C Clark said the following he
said the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible is to venture a
little way past them into the impossible
that's the origin of the name of my
podcast I want to ask you this in terms
of advice to to a 20 something 30s
something year old Mo what advice would
you give if you had 30 seconds to spend
with uh with young Mo what would you
tell him to give him the courage to do
as you've done to go into the impossible
I know the answer to that I I know that
now but I wish I knew that then life is
a video game whether that's actually
physics or not looking at it as a video
game actually gives you a massive
advantage
and and I and allow me to to to to
explain there is a a big difference
between playing tennis and playing a
bday tennis is a finite game where you
try to win and the world that we live in
has been positioned as a finite game you
need to become this title you need to
make this much money you need to get
this house and so on and so forth uh
when reality uh life is actually
infinite okay and and by Me by infinite
I mean the the game of life that we live
in here I think you know that at our age
you start to look back and say all of
those goals I set for myself once I
achieved them I kept moving and I set
other goals and other goals gos and that
you know I'm I don't know if I should
say this but I'm a very serious video
game it or not at my age with my
responsibilities I still game
professionally 45 minutes a day four
times a week I'm you know the game that
I play I mean probably two of every
million players have a chance to be
right what what game is that I I play
Halo H Halo okay yeah and and I'm an old
man so I play Halo you and Elon Musk
have that in common as well as your
personal net worth being very similar
yeah so so I I I'm the one that killed
Elon yesterday so
anyway the idea the idea is uh is this
huh true Gamers would tell you this true
Gamers would tell you there is one
objective to the game for an infinite
game which is not to win it's not to
advance in levels it's not to anything
the only objective is to become the best
gameer you have the potential to become
that's the only objective so so when we
game so when you game at the level I I
game at I'm not trying to achieve
anything other than perfect every single
shot and if I don't perfect it I repeat
it like an athlete it's an infinite game
okay and what is the best way to become
the absolute best gamer you have the
potential to become it's to play right
and that's what most people don't
understand that that I never succeeded
in anything that I did because I was
stubbornly trying really hard and I was
a little more intelligent than the
others or whatever I if I succeeded at
anything it's because I enjoyed what I
do so much and I absolutely loved it so
much that I kept trying and as I kept
trying I improved and as I improved I
became in some of those things the best
gamer out there okay which by the way
didn't even matter it it mattered to my
success but What mattered to me and
still matters to me is can I become a
slightly better game can I go into the
tough parts of life and you know compete
the part in those parts because it will
teach me to develop and grow it will
teach me to become better than where I
am today and and if you take that
approach to life suddenly something
amazing all of the pressure goes away
you don't really care if you make that
much or you don't make that much you
just care to to play and as you you care
to play you start to enjoy the G okay
you believe it or not you'll still
achieve the furthest uh potential you
can achieve because you became the best
person you can become but without the
pressures
that that is wonderful well Mo I want to
close with a with a quote from a a
fellow Muhammad or Ahmed and uh that's
the following statement of Ahmed zael uh
who said and I believe you will agree
with this he said and I should say akan
Zoel won the 1999 chemistry Nobel Prize
and I overlapped with him a little bit
at Caltech it was a just a wonderful man
he's got an Incredible Book I'd love to
talk about with you at some point but he
said the following said although there
exist in the world today some microbes
viruses of the Soul such as
discrimination and aggression science
was and still is the core of progress
for Humanity and the continuity of
civilization em Mo I want to thank you
uh for everything you've done for me
whether you knew it or not you're a
tremendous influence on me and I know
millions of people around the world soon
to be billions of people God willing and
I want to thank you for sharing so much
of your time with our our audience we in
the depths of gratitude which I know is
one of the core attributes of a happy
happy person I am really really really
grateful that you gave me that chance
Brian honestly first of all all of your
questions were unique and wonderful uh
you know I I've never had someone
comment on the idea of second low
thermodynamics as we were talking about
happiness uh but it's not that it's not
just that it's it's that you allowed me
to reach into my heart and talk about
topics that matter in a in a way that I
hope will be understood and expected and
uh I loved it I'm really really grateful
that you had me me too and anything we
can do to advance your mission is is of
course within uh within our goals so Mo
I want to thank you so much go to sleep
get some sleep I know you do your best
work and your best gaming at night uh I
won't ask you what your handle is uh
because you know you might you might
frag me one day but uh madat thank you
so much for spending time today the into
the impossible podcast and I hope to
meet you someday in person thank you
thanks for having